on va aller se mettre alors non
d'accueillir le camille combal fifi
tarek venez avec nous et enzo du garden
alors le principe est simple
le principe est très simple un je vous
explique alors c'est très simple oui
alors ici alors comme il l'a avoué hier
a que trois qui sont tellement il en a
remercié ce qu'on peut en rajouter et
razzoli radin vous avez quoi ils ont mis
que quatre trucs donc on peut jouer qu'à
4 pour le moment bien sûr tu ne joues
pas syfy tarek gilles verdez enora
bataille à la plein alors à quand c'est
alors vous pouvez rappeler le principe
l'idée on va tout choisir une carte
devrait apprendre à compter 1 2 3 on va
tous se retourner en même temps est
celui qui a la quarantaine de morts ce
soir celui qui se prendra segal nous
aimons la carte des morts c'est dur il
fallait appeler un graphiste tout ça ça
nous coûte une très bonne équipe donc
attention je mélange attention bien sûr
enzo tu ne joues pas le premier chat tic
le premier servi ce sera arraché un
poils des aisselles à la pince à épiler
d'accord et c'est celle-là à la pince à
épiler d'accord j'espère que ça va pas
tomber sur gildas alors je suis sûr que
non mais pour donner un point d'honneur
à donner on l'a bien fait à vous la
dirai si oui alors attention attention
c'est avec cette arme est forfait
g je m'arrête retourne et alex est parti
mais je les ai croisés - mais non aller
alors si tu as bien dépensé quelque part
reculé à paul jeunesse enzo qui va le
faire de quoi ta vie du nez je me les
rapides à chercher loin chercher à
shenzhen qu'avant à temps a passé il va
non la page
enzo vas-y mais bob à deux doigts dedans
regardez voici trois ans attention pas
ses 2e et 3e voilà c'est ça prenait 2,3
et on remercie parce que là vous
respectez pas les restes d'une séance
sans direction alors ils ont merci en
langue d'état
attention et c'est vous qui faites alors
un deux trois candidats n'en dit pas
prend tous âges y prenait l'envolée voit
la tension non 1 2 3 alors vous allez e
enzo tu vas devoir m
jardiner ans à linge sur le visage des
noirs fait pas plaisir mais là tu veux
aller si alésienne jetons predicting il
ce n'est pas le cas ça chauffe ça va
enora les i sur le visage les relations
entre chez verizon aux questions et vous
allez c'est parti mais à cnn
voilà il en faudra 10 1 ça va supporter
d'un bal à l'habitude un c'est déjà fait
et ombres été mises à sécher faut le
faire sinon c'est dans le cidre voilà
cinq c'est pas maradonna 2 à 2 pts 6
si si si si c'est pas mal
sa mère et qu'elle ouvre toi
plus que cinq luccin classé bon allez
poursuivre gentil tout recommencer allez
allez allez jo la dernière à l'est
attention attention on allait on allait
alors attention on va leur faire là
sachez que ce sera en trois fois pour le
dernier parce qu'on a des ballons ça
sera en deux fois d'accord on a des
ballons un ballon avec de l'eau et un
ballon avec de la farine
celui qui perdra donc on éclatera le
ballon au dessus de lui attention ce
sera bien sûr tout ça dont il devra
rester dans le silence bien sûr le
pétrole ses parents une carte on ne
regarde pas trop regarder 2,3 alors
alors alors bien sûr ça va se jouer sur
un des deux non pas du tout s'est passé
entre vous deux
attention à 3 en dessous on peut faire
moins d'enfants à 3 1 le 3
alors je vais vous dire je vous dirai
pas ce que je vais vous dire pourquoi tu
veux c'est pourquoi je vais le faire
parce que je vais faire mais je vais pas
le faire tout de suite c'est toi qui vas
faire un dock si je le fais pour enzo
âgé débat sur le fait pour un job je le
fais pour la france et bam et bâle ont
amené le ballon merci monsieur c'est
quoi le gage alors y aborde d'abord le
premier ballon merci merci tu es entre
le pet au dessus de ses fils et moi qui
fait ses comptes le percement qui fait
c'est toi qui le faisaient je vais te
porter que celui que tu aimais bien au
dessus des épaules arrivé au dessus de
la tête bien tu as tu en prends ton âme
attend des accusés à tort ya pire
attention
jamais
il y avait deux ballons c'était la
mauvaise nouvelle
c'est bien
là c'est très sympa merci je rappelle
que même s'ils sont remis dans trois
semaines
merci en tout cas vous resterez tous les
chiens